we have agreed on immediate operational
measures that should help reduce the
number of irregular migrants and save
life at the same time will train
equipment support the Libyan Coast Guard
to stop people smugglers and increase
search and rescue operations and we work
with the IOM to step up voluntary
returns from Libya two countries apology
and we will of course act in full
respect of Human Rights international
law and European values the European
Union and our actions will support Italy
and Libya it is our responsibility the
development of the international scene
remind us of how important a strong EU
is transatlantic cooperation remains an
absolute priority because it has until
now been a key pillar of the free world
at the same we know that today we have
no other option than to regain
confidence in our own strength there was
no sense of anti-americanism there was a
sense that we need to engage with the
United States just the same but we
cannot stay silent where there are
principles involved and as in any good
relationship we will speak very clearly
where we think that those principles are
being trampled on there is a great
degree of convergence among the 28 that
the European Union has a role to play at
a global level and now needs to lead
also at a global level